josef cap von herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video vor ort lockt die
leute tätig war gestern abend feiern und
es war relativ lange bestimmt nur und
leute morgen aufgewacht und hab mich
entscheiden gefühlt ich habe zwei tage
im finish wieder trainiert und hatte
gestern kein musiker was manchmal
natürlich ich gehe abends feiern und
wach am zweiten tag danach auf einer
habe ich dieses stück hier 1000 ich hab
dir passiert mit den machen heute ein
bisschen schwieriger geblieben und in
diesem wunderschönen stimmen video
machen wir ein kinect uk gefragt
wahrscheinlich der große von euch ok
übersetzt wird man ok das ist bullshit
noch ein bisschen was chip mit ist wenn
man irgendwie youtuber zusammen tut ja
daher ins leere
bei den meisten stücken hat auch darum
geht dass die zwei personen irgendwie
sexuell mit ihnen sind was ich jetzt
bewusst hier ausschließen möchte okay es
ist keine drei männer roman vielleicht
habt ihr euch auf anhieb direkt
verstanden glaubens nicht alle drei auf
anhieb gut verstanden also max in lucka
von anfang an ein iphone über einen
eigentlich für einfach andere stücke
haben viel miteinander geschafft und
luca merk
[Musik]
und gewissermaßen auch dafür versichert
videokanal weil ich den gemacht hat beim
markt gesehen hat gemacht hatte die
beiden hatten am anfang sehr gut
verstanden und ich hatte am anfang nicht
liefert so kann das kann man irgendwann
spät schon also lange lange lange
nachdem die beiden schon viel mit einer
getötet haben die nächste frage lautet
während der schlauste schrägstrich
dümmste von euch das ist gemeint ich
kann jetzt nicht sagen hey der der erste
dümmste und deren erste schlaueste die
drei unterscheiden und zu jeder seine
eigenen stärken
niemand von uns in genauso wie andere
okay die nächste frage wer von euch
wähler sich am öftesten die palme auch
könnt ihr euch gegenseitig hoch geht wer
von euch ist am verteiltes denn
eigentlich müsste man die anderen jungs
jetzt auch hier haben mark gut aber ich
würde sagen wir verbreitete bin schon
max ist auch gut verteilt werde gleich
familie üblich gute gute gene von
unserem vater geerbten luca ist gar
nicht so sehr verteilt denn er macht und
nicht nur in duell um platz eins
verpassten aber es würde eher sagen das
war das beste was wir zusammen gemacht
habt vergab erst mal einiges aber eine
sache die mir gerade sofort einfällt war
der moment ich will auch gar nicht viel
erzählen
ich weiß nicht ob es gut finden wenn ich
dinge empfehle deswegen halte ich ein
bisschen vage es ging darum wie hatten
irgendwann so ein gewisses ritual ist
bestand daraus dass einer von uns
ich sage jetzt nicht mehr ja diese
person ist auch garantiert nicht der
hersteller dieses videos betreiber
dieses kanals hier
irgend eine zufällige person auf diesen
drei leuten hat dinge gegen container
geschmissen
die anderen das mit schnaps wird gefilmt
haben und geguckt haben wie km/h dabei
rauskam irgendwie hat mir damit in
keinem halt fehler von steht und mich zu
verstanden wir haben einfach mit netzen
gefilmt wie wir dinge gegen dagegen
geworfen haben dagegen container
allerdings kaputten also gefilmt und den
km/h fit gemacht und da man darauf
achten uns darüber gefreut wenn die
geschwindigkeit hoch waren wenn die
geschwindigkeit niedrig war
dann war der wahlabend schon ruiniert
hat jemand von euch schon mal so einen
richtigen korb bekommen ja auf jeden
fall ich jemand bin ich wir haben du und
max luca kennengelernt max und ich fand
schon seit jahren jedes jahr auf
dieselbe und weniger unternehmen dann
haben wir auf dieser insel auch im
freundeskreis zu wollen wir auch liebe
hinfällt und irgendwann haben uns dann
wie ein jeden tag mit drei jungs da
verabredet aus dem freundeskreis mit kam
nach für uns gefahren mit dem fahrrad
aber hatten noch jemanden dabei und
diese personen die wie dabei hatten war
mittellos und ja wenn wir locker
finnland bürgerempfang rausbringen wie
würde erhalten also ganz ehrlich wenn
wir drei zusammen verbringen würden dann
hätte der 100-prozentigen rief die
hängengebliebenen nahmen dort leben gut
oder in meinen augen seid ihr
transvestiten alle wie geil wäre das
alter einfach seine fingerfertigkeit
wer kann am besten warten von euch drei
kann das wirklich vergleichen wer am
besten flirtet wenn damit eigentlich
umfragen sondern die mädels jungs oder
unbeliebten objekte mit denen gehörte
word flirtete nicht bewegt gewicht heben
stoffen geht keiner meisten flirten oder
hoch flirten aber ich würde sagen wer
ist der größte von euch der kleinste
also der kleinste markt dann komme ich
und lukas noch ein stück größer wird
könntet ihr euch vorstellen mal alle
drei zusammen zu wohnen
ich finde ich die idee nicht geil dass
man so eine youtube wg auf machen
einfach alle das gleiche ziel hat und
alle dieselben dinge machen weil das
einfach cool wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
aufnehme stehen meine beiden mitbewohner
in der küche und denken sich was zur
hölle ist los mit dem welche machen
müssen
nun würde und ich wirklich aufnehmen
würden halt einfach rein lassen und dann
würde mich irgendwann witziges machen du
schmeißt den laden hat alleine das heißt
rein youtube mächtig wäre glaube ich
schon sehr witzig aber ich glaube das
wird auf dauer einfach schon aufgeben
aber wer weiß was die zukunft bringt das
war für mich eigentlich gut mache ich
schon 35 minuten in der aufnahme aber
wie immer daumen nach oben
derzeit wissen wir mal 38 tore